about this hey man it's me Kevin Smith
Jason Mewes and we're live streaming
[ __ ] let's start a proper man every well
it's not Jane saw Bob get old it's what
we're gonna do what's in the box a
version of what's in the box so hey man
welcome to another stunning episode of
what's in the box I'm Beavis I'm but hey
there we go what we used to do on the
show what's in the box which is on the
YouTube channel is get a box of [ __ ]
open it up and see what was inside we
were always surprised we're gonna be
surprised bless you Chucky on this one
but the good folks at Spin Master sent
us a bunch of boxes of toys so we're
gonna go through all the toys man we're
gonna bust open every box and take a
look at [ __ ] man
it's a plethora of stuff hop hop hop hop
this dream come true and a lot of some
of them are kids toys and he's got one
of them a kid the kid
so a little version I've got an older
one says she's museum beyond toys unless
it's like a peloton
he's got age-appropriate kid who's like
oh I love toys
so some of this would probably be going
there others perhaps we'll be giving
away to you guys but we can't do
anything without doing the first steps
and that is where the maestro here takes
a box he takes a [ __ ] knife give me
the knife please and you guys here you
know what let me take this up try it you
know it's warm out here man it's right
and warm it's starting to feel like all
fornia again I already have trouble
talking to the mic I don't want you guys
not to be able to hear me I know I said
that so thoughtful look at that oh my
god he's more thoughtful yeah all right
he's got a knife he's gonna stab that
[ __ ] he's going look at that ya know
what's inside I don't want to ruin it we
don't know if we know all right here we
go what I'm seeing first in the box and
you know what I got a camera so I'll be
able to do
like close-ups on what's in the box oh
I'm not anything
do you see what I see all right so let
me put this here okay put this here and
there and the HDMI cables gotta stay in
so I'll hold on to that all right man
turn the box around a face like this yes
okay hold on let's let's show them
what's in the box ready just show them
the tip just the tip Batman mega gear it
is Batman with mega gear transforming
see a phone often sorry is it all three
of the same no I see another all right
that's pretty dope Batman mega gear all
right grip grab that I say something
very Sharky oh look at what bring it in
close bringing it close all right man so
this is the King shirt dude baby shucks
Chirk Chirk Chirk Chirk king cheese
shark shark shark shark nice look man
it's king shark and he gets to actually
wear armor mega gear man look at it's
like a backpack turns into an
exoskeleton shark monstrous blades of a
helmet piece oh my goodness I activate
power all right what's the third figure
that's it above all right here we go
guys get pop all right and here's the
last one
it's okay yes is to prepare to and then
the one like this you get one and I get
one yes
who gets shark shark
whoever gets well the shark goes to
whoever how do we decide who gets the
[ __ ] shark that's how about uh how
about Aaron paper scissors shark people
well but then how we're gonna let's say
people out there yeah you give us a Jew
means I'm opening another box
they don't it's not called what's in
their heads it's what's in the
let's see what's in the box all right
man here give me close-up Josh look at
that oh that's sweet man that's sweet
look at that I'm hosting I'm operating
cameras and [ __ ] this is like clerk
style
yeah there's old Josh over there give
you any tips whatsoever so it's a memory
all right pull it out here go to the
wide oh my god they gave us a box of
these little look Oh Lee [ __ ] man should
we open it yeah look at this it is the
Caped Crusader line of minifigures man
you get Batman you get Robin you get
Batgirl
you get Nightwing you get Red Hood Joker
these little fantastic bein a Clayface
is a Harley Quinn it's a scarecrow these
look fantastic man it's the what there's
one per you get to open it and then you
get to see what's inside ready to pop
pop up there you go so there is one of
them we opened was a Robin I just found
that up there so it's two two of them in
the box and he's not even in oh yes
sorry all right there we go something
else son as I get ready to roll give me
a close-up Josh
dr. Josh Roush on the mixing board
let me good one-two on down to the box
alright pull it out what is that it's a
vehicle oh [ __ ] son it's a Batmobile
two in one each act with an ejection pod
you jacked you let's see the bag let's
see the back we're happy those kids are
I've never been that happy about
anything in my life long I want to be
those kids and then lucky you get to
launch it looks at yes you launch a
Batman sits in there so I don't see a
bat I guess even the figure that Batman
figure in there man we're gonna pop this
out after we open a couple and I just
talk maybe I could just pop it out and
my god we have so many boxes to open
we'll play later on see what we'll do is
we'll open all these boxes and then when
the show's over me and Jay are gonna go
make a little commercial like the old me
go commercials were the Star Wars
figures commercials we're gonna go play
in my art and [ __ ] have the Joker and
and and [ __ ] King shark and Batman
jaxa bushes all right what do we got now
this is something there's a bunch in
here so let's pop open first but this
way this you're like you're too [ __ ]
close by ready to G oh they got 12-inch
whoa one let's go 12-inch poop Robin
boom I'm sorry one two yes it is all
Robin so let's not throw them all out
and then let's see the back of the
package ooh
so there's more characters to come all
right we don't want to know we want to
be surprised
all right just put the Robins up Robins
over here Robin's here here I gotta put
some over here you get to cutting
got keep [ __ ] moving so people don't go
like [ __ ] this I'm gonna go watch the
John Krasinski show that's good news
this is [ __ ] bad news
now we know just to pull one out yeah so
I'm gonna just pull one sold on go to a
close-up Josh and here he goes siga
Dugan areas the man himself I like this
version of Batman and it says rebirth
rebirth Batman's been around first
edition alright so that's a full box of
Batman thank you spin masters there we
go alright let's see something else the
boys found a theme ladies and gentlemen
this is exciting
Bubba bump give me a close Josh yeah oh
[Applause]
very nice alright here we go
look at that line up all right boom open
another one I'll see you see what there
I gotta read a little info on these
figures we keep opening them up but
there's got to be some info on them Oh
as we go should I pull it out or wait
for you all right hold on information as
to what we're stumbling through this I
am Batman I am Batman
I am bat meals it's a mask what do you
do with it man give me a close-up Josh
oh my god you know what you got to do
now you got it like [ __ ] laugh like
that wookie lady did so we go viral
Dorgan hip-hip dogging here take it all
and finish fix your hair and then do it
again and see if you could talk lower so
we don't hear you over Batman I hear
very low you're stronger than that
[ __ ] mic meantime I'm gonna try to
figure out what we're doing here what
what these are called so we can tell
people where to find them today and
Batman I am bettin open another box epic
missions the fate of Gotham City is in
your hands ladies and gentlemen this is
pretty dope man I mean I love these
pitmasters cats like I wish when I was a
kid somebody would have sent me a bunch
of boxes full of Batman toys that would
have been amazing all right hold on let
me get the camera I'm slacking on my
deep and ready go to go to close up Josh
tribe me he's something sweet you sure
we love the Caped Crusader put him right
here man so I could look at him real
close you this way all right and look at
that
let's QVC this [ __ ] all right start on
him and then go to my clothes oh dude
guess what oh my gosh guess what
well it looks like you put the
accessories in his belt and he actually
picks up each weapon when it spins I
believe that's why his bracelet
automatically changes three weapons yes
I was right so what do you mean like so
he yes he pulls that from his belt he's
the other belt belt spins
oh we can't we gotta like do that before
the end we got it like I'll open it up
real quick we'll attach those and we'll
show you guys I am the 9 I am Batman I
am use man all right let's see another
one here remember kids when you're
playing with [ __ ] at home
don't play with knives we need them
though to get in the boxes otherwise
we'd be using our teeth and [ __ ] all
right here we go
I'm a DP and I'm a host so I was trying
to see per minute you put one here and
then you could look at the other whoo
the Caped Crusader batcycle it's Batman
versus Clayface that's fantastic there
you go guys look at that man Batman
versus yeah it looks like so Batman
mount Oh defend yes whoo look at the
drawing on the oh yeah dude his variance
does again I like it
all right there we go so we'll put that
baby right there okay I'll put this here
this here and take this box look at all
these fabulous prizes man where do you
get all these wonderful toys on brand
all right here we go hold on oh just
alright yeah
let me see take one out to camera really
launches alright so you got a [ __ ]
man bat looks amazing that Nightwing
looks fantastic
I like them they're colorful it's not
all brewing it looks like you get two of
the same right there but that is amazing
bra one box Rose or what goes in the car
like that
probably the bad cycle yo bring me
everyone everyone go stab the [ __ ] out
of that and let's find out what's inside
like this and we'll pop it out right
sure I think these are a little
different or a little same I'm away for
you yeah oh my gosh wait you see this
action don't don't don't don't - that's
a nice King show could you doubles all
right look take that this box the three
it's all Batman's and one King shark is
the chase yes the juice yeah you have
four of these and two of the king shark
so these the harder item to find Oh
beautiful all right two more boxes of
joy left and there goes my phone please
tell me then crack it did but it don't
matter because we got a bunch of free
toys I'll pick it up it's dead all right
you're getting the pre-open
oh go down killer rock killer croc
killer croc Batman in swamp fatigues and
Robin I like a Batman in a shade of
green I wonder I feel like I bet that
glows in the dark maybe the sword and I
don't know if it all glows but they're
like rather than doing just like the
dark brooding Batman like this is Cape
Crusader II I wonder let me see yeah I
think believe that it's a four pack of
the same very nice very nice relieved
this alright and then our final box
ladies and gentlemen the fine
[Music]
oh snap we got more of these yeah it's
the same notes the same box joker bam
bat all the ones to thwart before the
dew blaze yes to blaze of that one
alright alright this is fantastic what a
haul
move over for they [ __ ] crucify us
what a haul what should we play with
first take that Batman out the one that
did the rapid change utility belt and
see if you're right fun thing about
Jason Mewes ladies and gentlemen his
name was on and still is on the store
Jay and Silent Bob's secret stash many
years ago he wanted a han Solo
riding a tauntaun to that we had in the
store and so Brian Johnson was running
the store at the time and he said I'll
let you do it on layaway you could pay
for it on layaway so Jay brought in like
five or ten bucks a week finally hit the
purchase price when he was officially
the toy was his he opened it right there
at the counter at the stash played with
it for two minutes
and then left it there and never picked
it up again so this you know is way less
expensive than that man because he gets
to open all these toys and he didn't
have to layaway for it the good folks at
Spin Master hooked us up all right man
let's see what it does cuz again it goes
in a direction but I didn't read it but
here we go ready nod that way but you
push it in the middle oh oh he
quickdraws puts it back whoo that is
dope man hold on let me let me get my
close-up camera on this action right
here all right your turn toward me
that's fantastic
does he keep changing gears he dropped
one on the thing that is dope so was a
work with magnets pulls it up Oh Batman
stronger than there we go one just one
do it again
you sure can that's fantastic
that is baptized let's take a different
weapon for every saying or phrase or
what have you he does it up and he goes
claw blaster hip-hip Dogon this is like
a Christmas and like we've just opened
everything and now it's like well what
do you want to play with first totally
open up that car this kids is what you
need right now you know a mask that's
what everyone's looking for right now
get get you one of these masks man
Batman will protect you this is dope oh
it shoves into right here yeah so now
it's closed kids right so you see the
back all full piece all right here's D
so there's the back we could put a
Batman in there if we wanted to shell
knows we have enough
it has a Snyder ish feel to it to the
front of the Batmobile let me put a
camera real close on it sorry not only
do we get the cool Batman that goes
inside I do my three accessories in here
it's like a little box Oh every figure
comes with it yeah and if I did it
cleaner just check that out so you get a
Batarang like gauntlets and a grapple
hook and what is that come with the math
student a chest plate so it's like
that's the thing it's like with all this
rice and eggs yeah surprise eggs and
stuff it looks like they're trying to
make you build like a figure kind of
thing we're build like outfits well you
get like these are surprises they're
like each Batman I bet if we opened
another same exact looking Batman that
in the box it comes with three different
items so let's see if I'm right good
mattaniah bat music the singing that
Batman take take man bat see what he
comes with okay do it slow and sexy I
want to make it last Locker let's open
up our locker of goodies Oh what is he
good
he gets clogged the marine nice you know
absolute scum each figure comes to the
locker and each Locker comes with three
little yeah and I just want to see
because it's the same bat I wonder if I
think I'm right that even if you get
three of these same because I was we
were might be a different toy at
different accessories with each bag yeah
so even if you bought like three Batman
you're like man I've three of the same
Batman I'm thinking that you get
different accessory
but I you know what this is not the same
Batman I'm telling you I gotta see if
I'm right here it is this is the same
Batman I opened no it's not wow there's
so many different ones actually so many
to choose from
I'll hold the mic that's like swords
yeah grapple hook I mean I just want to
collect the accessories oh that's dope
man so each even if you get the same
figure it comes with different
accessories a wicked smaht that's the
big thing I played these hidden eggs
these surprise eggs as a guy with a kid
you would know Luke Ren these are what
are the ages he's freeing up dude your
kid can totally play with king shark
let's see about shooting out this piece
yeah I don't know if it shoots out I
think it's just I type for some reason I
was like because don't come out the
floor right eject
it says eject but it's not an actual
ejection okay there's no actual ejecting
but you pull it out and then you're like
to the boat it's a boat look at that
yeah land sea water you are not safe
from the Cape musee de dooda dooda dooba
dooba dooba dooba dooba do we do I feel
like that's your line we got our own
personal Gotham my own private Gotham
right here man
I like do you think yeah oh I oh I got
to open up oh but there's only one of
these so this is the surprised one aw do
we open it or do we give it do we take
him it's really up to you I mean I mean
no I think someone might enjoy part of
me wants to open it because the actual
arms are smart exactly let's see where
to transform
I mean it's not a toy unless you pull it
out the box if we leave it on the box
it's just a collectible this is made to
be played with man this is the Caped
Crusader line once again thank you spin
masters for giving us something to do
and something to play with
let me see hold on let me get my little
camera in there go ahead Josh close them
up so it's cool so at first he has it
behind even his uh the helmet goes back
back so it looks like it's like a like
oh nothing to see here guys nothing to
see here and then all sudden he's gonna
fight super Superman who has a really
strong powers and stuff but he's like
what though again he's ready for the
Cape Crusaders very dope very dope man
it's so funny my casts are on fire from
the Sun behind us yes and what else I
mean we can sit here let's open up
everyone I'm just kidding yeah I'm good
we could spend all day opening this
stuff and we will just off camera but
did you like us opening up a bunch of
stuff ladies and gentlemen because we
sure liked it man oh man how about this
so we got a bunch of people watching on
YouTube bunch of people watching on
Facebook bunch of people watching on
your twitch let's how do we how do we
give this to people oh oh we got to
think of a good giveaway so how about
josh is going on what's a good way to
give away some gas he's trying to see
yeah there are some adults and some kid
because kids like toys as well who I
think would appreciate playing with some
definitely definitely let's see one no
no but then we don't know but again I
think it no shelters I think you said
honestly so many shelters are being
turned away turning away Salvation Army
and they were like not right now thanks
we're overflowing I'm just trying to
think if the best way something to do
with the stream like if you guys can do
stash tag J's twitch stream yes is there
like a border JY m e WS you can go to
Jamie use twitch twitch it now here it
is go to Amazon load twitch the apps
free it's and there's not you can put on
your phone well some of them don't I got
in Facebook YouTube will have you know
just like so how could you you should
distribute via your twitch page yes any
twitch like subscribers and stuff yes
and I'm gonna be streaming tonight on
Twitch from 8 shoving off the
responsibility to the states from a p.m.
Pacific time this is a p.m. to 1 a.m.
I'll be streaming on my twitch o-o so
come watch come hang out 1 a.m. yeah 5
hour yes sir come and we'll stop by that
stream and tell him to go be with his
wife like well I do that on Tuesday
Thursdays no no some because I'm keeping
some yeah I'll be honest with you the
[ __ ] the king sharks mine
particularly the metal one when you guys
get on yeah when they get on we can
figure out there's bunch different games
we can play marbles I mean sorry there's
dice before I've given to give away
right well yeah there's a marble game on
there yeah there's a digital marbles
there's a there's a I have a couple
dungeon and Dragons I 1 to 20 I have
people gasp first person will take your
stuff yes
so come watch I will have stuff lots of
stuff to give to you guys will figure
out when we're playing we're having fun
you know come check it out I always talk
for about an hour or so in the head of
the stream and then I usually jump into
some game you know depending on what day
it is and such but come hang out also
twitch prime yeah Amazon Prime Church
prime you get free subscription so hang
out Jay Mewes while he streams on his
twitch prime channel tonight you can
walk away with some of this one of these
real fun way for you to win it and he's
gonna think of that between now and then
many different games worthy people first
off I would I would prioritize people
with kids that's just me fair enough I
like who and the streams got a kid yeah
and I'm not saying at the expense of
adult kids I understand you like toys
too but you know if you got a kid and
you're stuck in the house for the last
few weeks some new toys I got some ideas
you'll see you'll see you got I guess it
might be you to man I'm glad you know
again we don't we get to I get to come
over here for this it's been like two
weeks before that I hadn't seen him for
almost a month so it's nice to get to
come over and do this and yeah man just
some I can't wait you know I get to
cuddle you again when I'm not streaming
for 5 hours
nooch will you help me make a little
commercial with this yes please we've
got so many toys we should do only we
can go in the woods yeah we go like in
the trees in the back of your yard and
swinging there on a cactus planet hello
there's a swamp place that we're halfway
there I like it I like it there it is
folks thanks for hanging out with us man
there was a box
there were many boxes and he cracked
them like an oyster
and pulled out all these pearls yeah
pearls worn by Batman's mom when Joe
Chill faces him and his parents in the
alley and we know what happens next
it turns them into the Caped Crusader
ladies and gentlemen put on the mask
let's go out with Batman let's hear and
try try talking low dude that's pretty
good I don't even hear you what parent
wouldn't want their kid running around
the house constantly having all that
like you know I would love to hear that
if I kept hearing my home run or house
going I am the knight I'm like you sure
I am
oh you could do your own put it here to
me very you're putting the mic to your
mouth which makes sense but there's a
speaker in the head remember Brian
warlin when he would sing you'd be like
Bruce you can hide from the Batman had
to intimidate criminals by like holding
a microphone to say more like is he
threatening himself I don't understand
desert I'm
city I am the night we're gonna sit here
all show and just do it like here do
this tell me do you bleed
that's batfleck good right now alright
folks thanks for hanging out with me and
Jay here on what's in the box for what's
in the box
I'm Kevin Smith Jason Mewes we gon
what's in the box spin masters Caped
Crusader's delish you can hide from the
Batman time